Ah there we go. So when Irish men yell. stop dropping out motherfuckers
huh, uh oh. ive gone horizontal.
so many prone people
I'm one of you
my girlfriend says hi
all of you shit your pants
what the button for chat again? B?
Yeah, very hitting here. I'm like Jeez oh my God
T for Terry what's up motherfuckers. Thanks for playing with us zombies
We appreciate you.
we're going right into the middle of the
gray triangle
I seeeeeee
- five six nah I see a smattering of zombies with us, but well the hope is that we get military gear here
So yes, we should we try to land on one roof
ummm land right there
Good, we're going next to the three titties. Oh
I'm kind of far behind you guys so oh there's a zombie right behind you mark. Oh shit. Oh
fake out right between you and me oh they landed on the roof of like the school building over here
Yeah, so they're there they're up on that roof of that gray school building that we just flew over
It's funny that the I'm right next to cars don't get creepy hello in this modal, okay?
We got ya one does a backpack for you latex. I'll take the backpack. Yeah you take that
Grab everything and I'm fine. Oh
Come on. Who's got a gun. Who's got a gun. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. I have a gun. Sorry
Oh awakened it was awakened
oh my god wade got awakened. Yeah
you dont need to be a dick about it wade, damn look Nada. It wasn't going to happen, but I'm not sure
There's a level two backpack on me. If anyone needs a bag I in the bag freyr here
There's scars, and there's m fours on me. I'm gonna come towards Jack then coming away. I'm gonna wait. Don't go
That's why we're here alright. I'll stay with you. It will study gonna. I kind of moved away. Leave you guys
I need that there's an auto shotgun on me as all stay at the minimum
Staying groups of two guys just watch each other's backs
Well one person's eluding the other person should just be like not okay, not in the menus. It's weird because
Sniper rifles are the thing you should be using for main game, but for this it's all a RS
Yeah, because you need as many bullets as possible
It's the big yeah, it's like but oh I don't have a lot of heals people have a lot of real
Yeah, I got tons of first aid kits
I've got a three all marked another M4 right there or if you'd rather have less than oh, no, I found another one later
So I got that so we need to get to a vehicle
so we should get moving like left towards the road and see if we can find a
Jeep or something uh the circles  partially on the island too, so we don't figure that for understand it and on the brakes
We should be good. Oh, well, we could run it
We're a little behind the times and we don't need to start running right now or find a vehicle
Yeah, there's no vehicle here
Then oh here's a motorcycle
It's a two seater two people could take that and try to find out the three theatres actually that's true
Three people can take that to try and  find other vehicle and pick one of those up, we got a plane coming our way
I don't know if its going to drop near us, but yeah, oh my God. It's off Jesus
That drop should land near us
Alright. Oh, we're right next to the circle
So literally you two can just run up a foot to get to the circle bob do you wanna
Go on a cruise for a car does everyone have sight I?
Have no accent 2x. I'm going on those I have no scope
Okay, I haven't read done. You can get 360 Noscopes wait. Here's a motorcycle
Yeah, don't get that's and then we'll have two sets sure all right. We got vehicles in case we need it
Okay, come to me. I have scopes on the way
I've got I don't have any magnification or am
Wait, wait wait chill Jesus. Whoa. What does looks like you just rode fast jacket like full-blast
Picking a red dot on me are we are we piecing out? Oh wait this?
Let me check did anyone check these buildings here mark
Did you know a good attachments cuz the same for is decked out? Yeah? I did yeah you take that
I got more attachments though. You sure one. Yeah, okay. I feel kind of better. Good answer
I'll go I'll go with uh well our jack don't forget to press x if you need more speed as well
What does that yep put your gun away, which makes you run faster?
That's right. It's basically taking out a knife and see it
I'm taking the five five six and again in the road while you guys search it. I've cleared my building
We're so fucking tryhard right now. Well we're not going to die like assholes
We're not zombies
In the first two minutes so that I can't believe if we've got to kill awakened at the very beginning of the game
Because that was kind of a sweet vengeance
if you guys find an extra extended mag or a quick draw for a
Assault rifle like an easel for the S12 but now I've got what for my main
So it's okay if you don't I think I've got quick draws on both my mains, but I don't have any extra stuff
Okay, I'm ready Pete's out whenever in it whenever it's a blue the blue is uh not actually that close neveress how people go give
me
Give me just a little bit longer
I'm just finding more ammo, and I know that ammo is king here, so yeah the ammo situation
I feel like I don't have enough and I have like 500 rounds of ammo between all my guns yeah, all right
Well should we get out of here? All right? I'm with
Alright. I'll go with you bubble. Oh, oh, I'm with okay city. Yeah
We know I don't want her here and let me get the other wah cuz I can show me more okay? Yeah
403 just don't shoot me because you can shoot me alright will not shoot you. Maybe please don't look. It's kind of my best
It's going to be a scooter of a chinky round, so oh oh yeah, we've only killed one zombie all this time
Do you guys want to play the bridge to get kind of a choke point, or should we move in oh God no?
That night we could mold out a bedroom
I will also keep an eye out for gasoline so we can fill this thing up if we need a quick bit away
I would play the bridge spot. Oh, what color are we going to not end there?
Better watch inxs. We are rich in the hell out
Things are not the way to know I was doing a great job driving
I got no problem with driving like an on insane person, so oh we're good. I know it'd be crazy
It's what I do yeah across this cornfield is terrifying though. Yeah. God. Yeah, oh
Just please not please don't understand but we're gonna kiss
I get nervous during normal pub G matches, but like 10 trips. I know my butthole, okay?
Okay, right that doesn't sound like something those okay?
The side of a building, what is with the fire?
let's get out, and oh, okay, right so uh
Okay, I'm not open here. Oh the doors are beating down there, Sam, sam. Oh, they're zombies of this building jack
I saw movement in here, okay. All right zombie. Are you fighting like you're at fight wait. I totally couldn't open doors
They can break them they can break them if doors are broken off the hinges it means there's zombies, okay
I'm checking people doing on med kits and boosters. We're good. I don't know first aid kit
Don't spend too much time in that house because there's not a balcony to jump off of which is terrifying
I had zero first aid Bob. You know I don't need any are we trying harding or not right now. We are tryharding
We're try harding. Oh captain. My cap. I'm tryharding but I know the game Bob
This is Gonna sound stupid, but I don't have a pistol yet
Zombie zombie coming in now stopped coming to the house which house no you're in our way
Okay
Okay, don't forget to follow when you're getting close
I'm gonna shout cut out this don't you have a little drop is landing on us I've got no no chuckles
I'm full all the way yeah. Oh, we got zero bandages zero perfect
Oh wait coming to me keep losing weight keep looting. There's a the drop is coming at 300 right now should we hey buddy
Wait for it to in here
Yeah
I object wade come to me
Okay
On my way there shit on the floor that you can use my eyes have never been so open in my goddamn life
I walk bro. Are you woke right now? Are you feel gettable? Oh, I'm not rose
Yeah, the drop is like in this be who?
They keep it tight boy. I don't see ana tombos running for it. Which is pizza a new sight?
Zombies want that awm that's going to happen
I would have hang back here with Bob while you to push forward yeah
I'm going to keep a little bit of a overwatch on you guys
We also have we also put chinky right next to a so that's a loot if we needed here
We lost them all I'm toast um I'm good okay. There's another plane coming into my shop right honest to
What do you have an eight times? Yes, I do
You know pSLV. I I gave away one to wade yeah, oh, I know
Okay, God Sarah leave, but he definitely did it who shot. Oh those the smoke all movement
There's movement run to the field from the earth what nautica. Oh, there's an M249 here. I see it
I see it. I see it that's coming for you
Jack you are in trouble
Okay, okay, wait. Keep watching me keep watching me
Okay, sick lag. I can't take what the shit off my God. We got behind us - oh
Shit, they're all around us make a way back to Bob boone waves. Come back this when I come back to slice wait
Are you still watching me am I good you're still good?
I thought I saw crawling in the grass to the south-southeast, but I think oh just a graphical glitch, okay?
I got an M249 so we're good
Nice, that's a good fine. So you have a hundred shots before it hits another drop one nine, five. Oh
Behind us behind the fence behind it yeah, I have three hosts
300m oh for this thing, so we're good. Oh, man. They're swarming backdrop. There are so many
300 right now oh, they're old
light them up light em up
All I have our iron plate oh
My God better. Oh boy. I don't fly them up. I don't like it right behind me
Behind you on the car. Wash it oh shit
Guys fight back to the motorcycles. It's time to go yeah, we got to go
humming hello there all of us
Fight back to the motorcycle to me to me to me whoo
On me on me on me up down. We are down right now
Thing does not reload quickly. We've got a shotgun. We getting pizza remotely
Oh boy, well last damn time
Mark out this come with me bastards. Come at me. Come on me the last one alive again
You want some of this oh?
I can't hit shit apparently
Run Turner run turn to run. Oh turn to run. Well. There's somebody down. I didn't kill a single one
You're a fucking beast. They're in a red zone though, but I got you know and all that. Oh well, I got grenada
Come at me
The exact same as last time 23 out of 25